are billionaires born rich or just lucky
the answer is mostly no they are also
people like us and many of them had
humble beginnings
this means they worked all those jobs
that no one wanted when they were kids
too
so in this video we will tell you about
the first jobs of famous billionaires
but before we begin if you're new here
and haven't subscribed to our channel
already make sure to hit the subscribe
button and the bell icon for interesting
tech videos every day
now let's get started
first on our list is elon musk
we all know about him his current net
worth is
160.4 billion dollars elon musk is the
charismatic founder of spacex the boring
company and the ceo of tesla motors
and he's capable of moving the markets
with just his tweets but how did it all
start he was a software engineer
technically at the age of 12 but he
wasn't just an average software engineer
because he actually programmed his own
space themed video game called blaster
which he sold to pc and office
technology magazine for 500
number two we have jeff bezos
he is a technology entrepreneur who has
played a crucial role in the growth of
e-commerce as the founder and ceo of
amazon
however bezos's first job was as a grill
operator at mcdonald's where his salary
was less than three dollars per hour
today bezos is the richest person on the
earth with a net worth of 208 billion
dollars next on our list is warren
buffett
warren buffett the most successful
investor of the 20th century and ceo of
berkshire hathaway with a net worth of
101 billion us dollars his first job was
a newspaper delivery boy for the
washington post in 1944
where he earned 175 every month during
that time his first job paved the way
for starting new ventures and helped him
to build salesmanship abilities later on
his rise began when he began investing
in stocks
number four is bill gates ceo of
microsoft with a fortune worth 131
billion dollars according to forbes who
doesn't know microsoft's bill gates well
his first job was that of a computer
programmer
this harvard dropout followed his
passion for tech from a very young age
and his first job was as a computer
programmer for tiata blue during his
senior year in high school at the age of
15.
later on he met steve balmer and paul
allen and started his own software
company microsoft the rest is history
number five oprah winfrey
her current net worth is 2.7 billion
dollars according to forbes
her first job grocery store clerk she
was a television producer american talk
show host actress and the list goes on
when one thinks of talk show hosts we
often think of oprah winfrey first don't
we winfrey got her start in an average
menial job at the grocery store back in
the 1960s she was only 16 at that time
later on she quickly moved to
broadcasting read the news for the local
radio station and created an empire of
media with her iconic the oprah winfrey
show
number six on our list is giorgio armani
his current net worth is 7.5 billion
dollars his first job was a
photographer's assistant in 1957
well before his signature suits changed
the fashion world giorgio armani served
in the italian military it was during
this time he got intrigued with fashion
during his military vacation he helped a
photographer earn some extra money at a
department store that was his first job
after his military service he went on to
work at la renocente a well-known
department store in milan where his
design career started
lastly on our list is richard branson
his net worth was 4.8 billion dollars
according to forbes he isn't known for
doing anything on a small scale so it
may not surprise you to learn his first
job was publishing his own magazine
after dropping out of high school at 16
years he started a youth culture
magazine called student which was for
students and run by students
the first edition sold eight thousand
dollars worth of advertising which
covered the first run of fifty thousand
copies
branson started virgin as a mail-order
business to help fund his magazine
efforts it later evolved into record
sales and eventually a record label we
all know that starting out as a
newspaper boy or a software engineer
doesn't guarantee that you will be a
billionaire but have you ever wondered
how these people became successful
well they discovered their passions at a
very young age be it technology
investment fashion or art and kept
working towards it
do you two dream of becoming rich and
successful like them well let us know in
the comment section below and get
started towards it right away see you in
the next video thank you for watching
and stay tuned to simply learn for more
such interesting videos
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here